foreign
this year North Korea is dealing with
several uh unique unique factors that it
hasn't had to deal with uh in many of
the in many of the previous years
um one of the most significant factors
is of course the implications from the
pandemic it's not simply the
meteorological conditions and the the
farming conditions that are going on but
it's that lack of international AIDS one
and then two and now three years that's
starting to build up and that's why we
see this as a particular worry this year
[Music]
um
thank you
[Music]
North Korea's agriculture system relies
on Farmers producing as much food as
they can and that that all going into a
sort of central distribution system that
is handled by the state in the past that
provided North Koreans with an adequate
supply of basic nutrition but over the
last sort of 10 years or more it started
to fall apart and it's at the level now
where most North Koreans can't survive
on what if anything they get from the
state now a lot of that food that is
grown goes into capital cities where the
elite live and then also to Army units
and and the military and places like
that
[Music]
North Korea can't afford to keep all of
its undefized nourished properly yet it
has a program to develop nuclear weapons
it is launching missiles all the time
it's putting a satellite into orbit this
year all of that costs a massive amount
of money and it appears that agriculture
is definitely second to all of that
there doesn't seem to be very much
intervention from the government in all
of this
the UN is very keen to get in the world
food program to start helping and there
are several private Charities and Aid
groups that want to get in as well so
that's also going to be important for I
think the Harvest this year and in
coming years is is how much North Korea
kind of admits it has a problem and
accepts help from overseas because it
definitely needs the help by all the
metrics we can see this is usually a big
problem in the country and this year it
just could be really really bad